euh pour j'ai on a deux débats
aujourd'hui donc vous allez réagir à
l'autre c'est la fille Raquel garido et
Alexis Corbier vous pouvez rester
d'ailleurs là-dessus j'aimerais voir
votre ami placé en garde à vue pour
apologie du terrorisme les parents
sont-ils responsables et oui elle a été
interpellée par les enquêteurs de la
brigade de répression de la délinquence
contre la personne elle est soupçonnée
d'apologie du terrorisme et provocation
publique et directe non suivie des faits
de commettre des atteintes volontaires à
la vie rappelez-vous une vidéo que
d'elle avait tourné sur les réseaux
sociaux
regardez je suis antisémite je m'en bat
les couilles j'assume
je voilà on va voir la réponse de Raquel
garido si on peut la mettre la réaction
de de Raquel garido qui a donc réagi
aujourd'hui merci Stanislas Rigot de
venir nous rejoindre président
génération Zemo et porte-parole
reconquête euh donc les parents d'Ines
donc les députés LFI Raquel garido et
Alexis Corbier ont réagit cet après-midi
VI a une déclaration commune sur X nous
voulons tout d'abord exprimer avec
émotion notre compréhension et
affectation auprès de toutes les
personnes choquées à la lecture ou à
l'écoute des propos ou expressions qui
sont diffusé dans cette affaire nous
comprenons l'intérêt du public et de la
presse pour notre famille nous pensons
cependant indispensable de faire une
stricte distinction entre nous sur
lesquelles incombe en tant que
personnalité politique de premier pr des
obligations de transparence et de rendu
de compte et nos trois enfants qui non
seulement n'ont pas cette obligation à
l'égard du public mais doivent au
contraire bénéficier d'une protection
totale totale de leur vie privée de leur
intégrité physique et morale
inévutablement mise en danger par la
curiosité ou la malveillance suscitée
par l'identité de leurs parents euh ça
c'est n'importe quoi excusez-moi parce
que c'est pas on lui a pas demandé de
faire des vidéos si elle faisait pas de
vidéo c'est pas des vidéos comme ça
personne nirait chercher voilà c'est
n'importe quoi non mais eux ils disent
mais eux c'est toujours à côté de la
plaque excusez-moi c'est elle qui fait
des vidéos inadmissibles avec apologie
du terrorisme après il dire oui mais il
vous laisser parce que c'est c'est notre
fille oui bah il faut faut faut pas
essayer de savoir qui qui qui est la
personne qui a fait ça non mais c'est
des fous excusez-moi g je pense que vous
allez les défendre une fois de plus que
ce sont vos amis mais voilà il ressort
de nos conversations avec Ines qu'elle
déteste et réprouve le racisme et
l'antisémitisme mais les mecs
mais en fait en fait cette réponse est
une blague c'est une blue c'est la
Meille on va laisser derrière remettez
la vidéo s'il vous plaît Remz la vidéo
remettez la
vidéoette vidéo je m' les
couilles non mais c'est incroyable non
mais franchement dit dans une vidéo SNE
qu'elle ne plignz pas les victimes du 7
sepobre en fait en fait les amis de Gill
osent tout voilà c'est à ça qu'on les
reconnaî c'est à ça qu'on les reconnaî
excusez-moi nous restons à la totale dis
disparition du public disposition y
compris nos adversaires politiques pour
aborder les sujet auquel renvoie les
captures d'écran incriminés à savoir
l'antisémitisme et le massacre du 7
octobre 2023 par le Hamas sujet majeur
sur lesquels nous nous sommes déjà
souvent exprimés on lui a rien demandé
on lui a pas demandé de faire des
communiqués à Raquel garedo fille
attendez attendez sa fille 21 sa fille a
21 ans elle assume elle a fait une vidéo
où elle dit qu'elle est antisémite
Raquel garido c'est ta fille c'est trop
elle merdé merdé on t'a pas demandé de
faire des communiqués pour nous
expliquer que c'est tes copains les
opposants politiques qui font ça dans
ton dos c'est pas les opposants
politiques il y a un cas il y a un cas
moi ce que je demande maintenant elle a
21 ans c'est une adulte elle est majeure
comme on dit vaccinée il y a un cas il y
a le footballeur Youssef hatal qui a
fait la même connerie il a fait une
dinguerie il a fait une grosse dinguerie
il a pris 8 mois de prison 45000 €
d'amende voilà c'est tout il y a une J
pr va voir on va voir les tweets parce
que la question la question qu'on vous
pose chez vous c'est est-ce que les
parents les parents sont-ils
responsables voilà la FEL garido Alex
c'est bon c'est bon c'est bon les
parents de Raquel garido Alexis corbert
placé en garde à vue pour apologie du
terrorisme les parents sont-ils
responsables Stanislas Rigo pour vous
bah bonsoir c'est toujours compliqué
parce que évidemment quand ça touche à
la vie familiale quand ça touche à la
famille on comprend qu'il se sent
attaquer tout n'est pas forcément de la
faute de garido et Corbi et Dieu sait
que je ne les porte pas spécial
souvenir avec eux un peu Mouv à côé en
revanche moi je pense que corer et garid
ils sont coupabl d'une chose très simple
c'est qu'ils font parti d'un parti qui
s'appelle la France insoumisee qu'on
pourrait appeler la France islamiste qui
lui ce parti
véhicule des idées qui peuvent
s'apparenter à de l'antisémitisme je
prends plusieurs exemples mais on l'a vu
sur l'affaire du Hamas ou Danielo Bono
par exemple les qualifies de résistance
on l'a vu quand Mélenchon participe à la
marche contreantisémitisme on l'a vu
quand Monsieur Mélenchon défil avec le
CCIF et je crois que quand Zemour il y a
quelques quelques mois quelques années
débattait ici avec Mélenchon en disant
qu'il était le représentant parfait de
l'islamoguchisme il avait raison et
d'ailleurs le vrai duel en réalité de
fond c'est ça c'est l'Aline Zemo face à
laline Mélenchon et quand je vois ce
genre de tweet pardon elle a 21 ans
c'est plus c'est plus une jeune enfant
elle sait ce qu'elle fait elle l'assume
elle doit être sanctionnée et d'ailleurs
je va même aller plus loin si n'importe
quel individu avait fait une vidéo qui
avait circulé sur Twitter pour dire la
même chose elle aurait quand même fait
du buzz c'est pas pas parce que c'est la
fille de gar cor cette vidéo fait du buz
en train ce que j'étais en train de dire
après je pense ça aurait fait un peu
moins de buz parce qu'il y en a plein
comme ça il y en a plein comme ça ce
serait moins intéressé à elle aussi on
va se retrouver dans un instant on va
continuerdessus puis il y avait Raquel
garido qui avait dérappé dans balance
ton poste on se rappelle c'est ils ont
ressorti la vidéo là en fait c'était
c'était avec je sais plus quel animateur
mais je peux pas le blirer Corbier a été
interpellé par les enquêteurs de la
brigade de répression de la délincence
contre la personne hier elle a été
placée en garde à vue elle est
soupçonnée d'apologie du terrorisme et
provocation publique et direct non suivi
des fait de commettre des atteintes
volontaires à la vie elle est mise en
cause pour les messages qu'elle a
diffusé sur les réseaux en octobre
dernier quelques jours seulement après
l'attaque meurtrière du Hamas ainsi que
pour la vidéo que nous venons de voir il
y a un instant le parquet de Paris a
déclaré une enquête est en cours à la
suite de signalement adressé au pôle
national de lutte contre la haine en
ligne par des associations de lutte
contre la discrimination Jean-Michel mer
vous trouvez que les parents sont
responsables oui en quelque sorte je me
trompe peut-être mais voilà déjà ce que
je trouve dans la lettre ce que je
trouve dans c'est qu'il demande une
certaine décence c'est vrai qu'on est
parents on a toujours envie de protéger
ses enfants donc je peux pas leur
reprocher ça je je sais pas s'ils
auraient eu la même ils auraient appelé
la même descence si ça avait été la fils
le fils d'un autre homme politique de
l'autre bord qui avait été sétait
retrouvé dans une sauce je penseils
auraient été les premiers à aller avec
dans le sens de la meute et attaquer le
l'enfant en question deuxièmement ils
disent la lre je trouve ça un peu facile
genre on a été discuté avec notre fille
dans sa chambre elle nous a assuré
qu'elle était absolument contre toute
forme de racisme
d'antisémitisme leur fille qui est si
prête si prompte à faire des vidéos
pourquoi elle-même n'a pas fait une
vidéo pour dire j'ai dérapé j'ai dit
absolument n'importe quoi je m' excuse
j'ai choqué les gens évidemment je je je
trouve ça absolument horrible ce qui
s'est passé elle l'a pas fait c'est les
parents qui parlent à sa place et cetera
et troisièmement euh voilà je pense que
inè garido vit dans un milieu assez aisé
dans une famille aimante où les avec des
gens intelligents même s'ils utilisent
pas forcément leur intelligence à
abontion mais voilà où les les repas les
dîners les repas ont été nourris de
discussion politiques national et
international et je pense pas qu'un
enfant accouche de théories comme ça
comme ça tout à coup par hasard je pense
que quelque part il y a un Terrero
familial a cette forme d'antisémitisme
et je pense pas qu'elle l'inenté c'est
ven nul par vous êtes d'accord euh moi
je pense qu'il y a vraiment un gros
terrro antisémite chez LFI et qu'elle
doit avir un gros terro familial aussi
quand je vois ce qu'elle écrit ce dont
elle rit quand je vois les les enfants
cette famille qui qui était à ce
moment-là séquestré par le Hamas euh et
que elle nous sort des trucs comme ça ah
les enfants je les trouve intenabl euh
même plutôt chiant sur tous les gosses
voilà comment on peut avoir être AB à ce
point à à avoir une telle détestation de
de l'humanité parce que les personnes
considérées sont juives et que pour dire
qu'on est pas antisémite on va dire ah
non moi je suis juste antisioniste je
suis pas antisémite parce que ça on
l'entend tout le temps mais tout le
temps et moi franchement moi ça ça me
met hors de moi quand je vois des vidéos
comme ça quand ce qui s'est passé le 7
octobre moi j'ai vu mes enfants ça ça
aurait très bien pu arriver et je trouve
ça anormal que chez LFI ils maintiennent
ça avec les es de résistance les ceci
les cela et et donc elle qui arrive et
qui vous dit alors elle même plus
antioniste à dit moi je suis anti s my
ouais et alors bon ben écoute bravo
bravo c'est bien c'est des choses qu'on
ne peut pas laisser passer surtout en
France on peut pas laisser passer de
tels propos c'est inadmissible et je
pense moi que c'est dû à l'éducation
qu'elle a reçu du climat familialqu elle
était et donc Alfi et leurs idées nous
abond juste il y a une personne qui est
bien passé qui me dit en tout cas que
leur fille est une terreur apparemment
et qu' ils en ont bavé avec elle Alexis
et Raquel et que il la tiennne pas du
tout voilà c'est était même pas au
courant he parce que c'est un pseudo ils
l'ont peut-être découvert et ça ça on le
saura peut-être plus tard et cetera mais
encore une fois ce qui est intéressant
et je reviens sur ce que vient de dire
Jean-Michel mer mais quand on voit la
France insoumise qui par exemple avec
une une jeune femme comme Marion
maréchal Marion maréchal Le Pen qui est
not tête de liste aux européenes ils lui
font depuis maintenant 30 ans le
reproche d'avoir eu comme grand-père
Jean-Marie Le Pen là quand c'est un camp
qui n'est qui ne leur plaît pas quand
c'est la droite alors là par contre dès
qu'on est la fille ou le fils de
quelqu'un ça tape at tire la volo ça
tire la tire la Rigo pardon ça tire de
partout il y a plus de cadeau qui est
fait j'ai vu le débat mathil Panau face
à Mar maréchal elle ne se prive pas une
seule seconde de le ramener à ça donc je
trouve qu'il y a aussi une hypocrisie
ass incroyable Gill tu penses pas que
les parents soient responsables pas du
tout voilà toi tu penses c'est voilà que
leur fillees la tiennent pas moi je suis
quand même làdessus je suis un peu
d'accord avec moi je penseelle pas été
bibronné à des discours antis qu' fait
inadmissibleou
s pr je ne crois pas et je ne suis pas
d'accord avec Jean-Michel sur ce terrro
familial antisémite préparé
exactement on c'est mon avis ils ont
condamé contrairement à la de la l un
hasard si ça arrive le 14 novembre c'est
pas un hasard si ça arrive à un moment
où la France insoumise a tenu des
discours extrêmement fallacieux après ce
qui s'est passé le le le 7 octobre où
ils n'ont pas été très clairs vis-à-vis
de l'antisémitisme donc elle répète que
c'est pas je pense que je pense que on
est dans un environnement et dans un
terrro qui fait que jeis pas d'accord
avec mais bon on va voir qu tu en penses
moi je pense pas qu'il soit responsable
parce que par exemple moi je suis
polonaise en Pologne il y a beaucoup de
de racistes il y a les gens sont très
fermés d'esprit ma famille il sont très
fermés d'esprit et quand j'étais plus
jeune bah je l'étais aussi quand
j'avaisle 10 15 ans j'étais tous fermés
mais après quand on grandit bah l'esprit
se développe on a notre pr façon de
penser comprend que des conneries tout
ça et du coup bah maintenant j'ai ma
PROE façon de penser et je pense qu'à
son âge elle aussi elle devrait avoir sa
propre façon de penser ouais Moon toi
tuas du caractère elle ai voilà Hugo tu
penses que les parents sont bah moi je
pense que quand déjà tes deux parents
sont politiques c'est déjà un cas assez
particulier et qui sont aussi investis
dans leur mission ils ont une idéologie
qui est très forte donc je ne peux pas
imaginer que leur enfants n'ai pas
participé à des débats houleux autour
des tables des dîners entendre plein de
choses qui ont qui ont forgé un opinion
très clair donc je ne dis pas que les
parents sont antisémites mais je pense
que il y a quand même une démarche
politique qui lui a laissé l'opportunité
de s'exprimer comme ça face caméra parce
qu'elle voit qu'elle est filmé euh donc
moi je pense qu' ils ont leur
responsabilité s' avait qu'un seul des
deux parents qui étaient dans le dans la
politique j'aurais peut-être un doute là
les deux et aussi fortement ça me paraît
quand même voilà moi moi je pense moi je
pense l'inverse au contraire parce que
je me dis peut-être que le fait qu'elle
est baigné justement avec les deux
parents qui font de la politique pas un
deux c'est la c'est pas la double pine
mais c'est très rare c'estàd que tu es
baigné là-dedans ton enfance c'est pas
une enfance comme quelqu'un d'autre moi
je pense que peut-être ça marche quand
tu as 10 ans ce que tu dis 12 ans
peut-être comme elle a dit Polska 14 ans
mais à 21 ans 21s jeai vu ans sur la
vidéo
dirit sauf qu'elle a 21 ans je pense
vraiment que c'est ses idées à elle et
qu' c'est pas par rapport à ses parents
et ses parents sont pas responsable et
une fois de plus moi je demande qu'elle
soit qu'elle passe ce soit jugé ça et
comme le footballeur parce que le
footballur il a pris 8 mois juste qu'on